c'est le moment way to what to say 4
nous nous sommes le tribunal n'entend
pas rejoindre kg qui condamne les
messieurs comme hélas avec une panne de
sens tout le monde il est coupable
nous en faisons le serment avant que
vous ne passiez à tarbes où ma question
de mentir au moyen de s'en sortir
y'a vraiment épi
eva gang des barbares
je vous rappelle que léon zitrone est
inculpée d'atteinte à la sûreté de
l'état et aux institutions républicaines
puisque tous les prétextes lui sont bons
pour faire à la télévision l'apologie de
la monarchie est également il est
inculpé d'attentât à la pudeur et même
pour être plus précis de pratiques
sadomasochistes puisque en effet il
domine le sujet il maîtrise la langue
est une chatte ils l'engagent et comme
si cela n'était pas suffisant il faut
être devant tout le monde
la justice va rendre bien sûr tout à
l'heure son verdict mais nous on sent
écouté le courroux du peuple français
qui s'exprime par la voix du défenseur
de la société
le procureur général de la république
des proches française
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
françaises français belges belge mon
président mon chien monsieur l'avocat le
plus badinter coucher la cud subjectif
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri pour la cour avant d'en venir
directement aux cas qui nous préoccupe
aujourd'hui qui vous préoccupent devrait
dire personnellement je n'ai rien à
[ __ ] je voudrais faire d'abord une
importante déclaration d' introduction
liminaire ce qui constitue à l'évidence
un épouvantable pionnat ce qui passera
dieu merci inaperçue la pratique et le
bon usage de la langue étant tombée en
désuétude à peu près partout sauf hélas
sur les sommiers infâme où la jeunesse
obtuse et ignare de ce pays moribond se
livre sans vergogne à de satanique débat
gymnastique à thouars que la morale
réprouve
en dehors des liens sacrés du mariage
par lesquels seul l'homme et la femme la
main dans la main et la zigounette dans
le pilou pilou
lyon iront sans mollir vers les matelas
qui chante alors comme sa bande de jurés
sous doués végétatif gorges et
d'inculture crasse et de coca cola tiède
quand on vous parle d' introduction
liminaire vous ne voyez pas où est le
pléonasme
non je suis même certain monsieur
zitrone comme entendant parler d'
introduction liminaire
la plupart de ces iconoclastes de la
linguistique s'imagine être tombé sur un
cours de ce demi artisanale
monsieur le procureur oui je vous prie
de m'excuser mais j'ai oublié mon
dictionnaire des proches français et je
ne comprends pas je vous allez
comprendre
j'ai dit liminaire j'ai pas dis
luminaires en main fait que vous êtes
ça va ça rentre
hélas dieu me tripote hélas hélas hélas
qui dans ce beau pays de france est
encore parler sans l'écorché la langue
de nos pères qui à part nous de léon
qu'on est les derniers qui dans cette
époque je serai était heureux de n'avoir
pas vécu au niveau de la culture dont au
sujet de laquelle je suis était si
consterné à vous pouvez rire vous pouvez
rigoler amputé de la syntaxe diminué du
vocable handicapés de la sémantique
castrés du verbe émasculé du subjonctif
l'expression émasculé du subjonctif
pourra vous surprendre monsieur zitrone
mais vous savez comme moi que devant un
subjonctif
il y a que et des cons couple qu' il ya
émasculation puis comment osez vous
comment osez-vous consternant porte
drapeau de l'indigence culturelle des
temps modernes
comment osez vous vous moquez de cet
homme qu'on humilie aujourd'hui dans ce
box alors que l'exemple du pur langage
qu'il distille sur nos ondes et nos
antennes constitue à l'évidence l'un des
tout dernier rempart de l'occident
contre l'invasion barbare des charabias
anglo saxons entendez-vous dans nos
campagnes mugir ces féroces rosbif ils
viennent jusque dans nos bras pour
écorcher knows who is no passe montagne
aux armes citoyens
j'en demande une nouvelle fois pardon à
la défense passive qui est matérialisé
ici comme chaque jour par l'avocat le
plus badinter ici présent je devrais
dire ici absent l'hibernation précoce
dans laquelle il se fige avec soin
constituant l'essentiel de son
savoir-faire judiciaire ainsi qu'ils
l'expriment présentement avec éclat son
maigre derrière rudement avachi sur
l'oreiller en écaille de morue que sa
tata rodriguez lui envoie de lisbonne en
paca fado
j'en demande pardon à la défense passive
disait 'je mais je vais une fois de plus
de voir piétiner ses plates bandes
en prenant les parties de l'accusé le
parti à la base justement je voulais
dire le parti la clé voilà vous voyez
voilà ce qui se passe quand on respecte
pas la langue française si je prends le
parti de l'accusé ça fait bien si je
prends les parties d'accuser ça fait mal
non mesdames et messieurs les jurés
non je n'accablerait pas les onze y
trône bien sûr il a failli ôter à
longueur de jour de france avec les rois
les reines les présidents les boussac
les chevaux la reine d'angleterre pompon
poupou l'archi de mes fesses du
luxembourg le prince pipeauté d'andorre
le trou duc d'orléans la marquise de
pompes l'amour le compte de la roche
faux culs le chancelier de l'échiquier
tous les faux régnant du forez au père
du foreign office du foreign et
saint-esprit abel
[Applaudissements]
il a fait tout cela le bougre mais mais
avec quel langage quel vocabulaire
c'est pourquoi je vous le demande en
votre âme et conscience mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
peut-on raisonnablement en vouloir un
homme qui a su garder sa langue aussi
belle qu'au premier jour après avoir
léché tant de monde il y à 11 roi encore
en exercice dans les pays civilisés je
parle pas des [ __ ] dans les pays
civilisés
mesdames et messieurs les jurés sans ces
onze roi et une poignée de propriétaires
de chevaux moribond qui se tasse de plus
en plus sous leurs hôtes forme pour
échapper au fisc et à la grippe
espagnole
de quoi ce brave homme utile pu parler
dans jour de france le journal des
petter dans la soie la seule fois qu'on
a vu la photo pleine page d'un ouvrier
d'un jour de france c'était celle de
valises à étonnant en fait sont invités
d'aso avant qu'il meure
oui c'est morne grabataire hip hop fils
ses mornes grabataire lipophiles on
aspire rien on avale lâche on avale on
peut avaler le hajj oui c'est morne
grabataire lipophiles qui clique est
dans leurs vieux zoo au soleil de
longchamp sont les seuls les ultimes
pâture journalistique de l'accusé avec
je le répète les derniers rois fainéants
du vieux monde qui ne sont plus que onze
certes mais est ce sa faute à lui si
léon zitrone
elle sa faute à lui est sa faute à ce
sympathique mines odeurs mondain sa
charmante obséquiosité naturel n'at-elle
pas plus fait pour le prestige de la
france dans le monde que jojo brac
mouche pour le prestige de masseur rue
blondel talleyrand talleyrand qui
savaient nager sur le dos et ramper sur
le ventre comme personne talleyrand qui
était à l'opportunisme ce que va-t-elle
fut à la queue c'est à dire 1 m et là je
le répète à l'intention des garçons de
feu de fermer des étudiants lettres qui
nous écoutent par milliers et qui
croient que va-t-elle et une eau
minérale
on peut très bien vivre sans la moindre
espèce de culture georges marchais a
fait et fait encore d'ailleurs une très
belle carrière politique en restant
persuadé kossmann malesherbes et
périphériques sont des maréchaux
d'empiré
et en géographie dette encore plus nuls
il croit que varsovie c'est dans la
banlieue de moscou talleyrand disait
talleyrand qui avait oublié d'être con
sinon il aurait jamais été avec
d'adhérents qui a servi de son vivant
tous les princes qu'il a pu talleyrand
qui a vécu tellement courbet qu'on a pu
l'enterrer dans un carton à chapeau
talleyrand qui trahissaient à versailles
comme on pète a pas si c'est à dire sans
bruit c'est une licence poétique
talleyrand redirige sur son lit de mort
eut ce mot charmant à l'adresse de son
fils léon snu coïncidence son fils léon
deux fils léon donc de talleyrand qui
attendaient d'être assez grand pour
pouvoir fayoter sous le second empire
il lui dit ceci mon enfant en vérité je
te le dis il vaut mieux éviter les peaux
de banane en traversant le nouveau
régime que traverser l'ancien régime en
s'enfonçant des poules canards
voilà vous comprendrez aisément mesdames
et messieurs juré que mon respect de la
langue et du mot juste m'interdit de
terminer par une déclaration liminaire
je m'en tiendrai donc là et vous servir
et l'introduction du réquisitoire
d'aujourd'hui dans la conclusion de la
plaidoirie de demain et je vous laisse
avec le mickey et à demain si vous le
voulez bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est non non